why stop in California the far left now
calling for a nationwide reparations
payout
Squad member Corey Bush introducing a
bill that would give are you ready 14
trillion dollars worth of reparations
for black people who are descendants of
slaves
America must provide reparations if we
desire a prosperous future for all
222 million hours of forced labor which
today would be at the value of over 97
trillion dollars when we can send money
abroad to help elsewhere we have to make
sure because we're talking about helping
with things that are happening now when
we did not repair what happened before
I am going to talk to you Tom shallou oh
yeah
14 trillion we're already what 33
trillion
in debt yeah where's Newsom on this the
thing is did he came out strong about
the reparations until they started to be
a reality and we haven't heard from him
have we he's with Comey somewhere yeah
he's hiding because anybody who's
realistic about this knows it's a
completely goofy idea it's off the
charts expensive it's not even a good
idea to begin with so I you know it's
not a budget issue it's a bad idea but
they're not going to be able to pay for
it they can't pay for all the other
stuff that's going on in California so
no it's a ridiculous idea I think Gavin
Newsom wanted to propose it so he could
run for president and he thought oh
they're never going to do anything about
it and now that they are doing something
he does want to run and hide you know
Congress Dana is this going to get
Traction in Congress I don't care if it
does because you know what politically
this is great for Republicans right
because under the Democrats logic one
person presented a bill that would have
reformed entitlement spending in the
future and that turned into all
Republicans want to throw granny off the
cliff and take away your Social Security
and Medicare so I think turnabout is
only fair play so all the Republicans
can now say that the Democrats want to
do 14 trillion dollars of reparations
and just hang it on them now the White
House has been very careful to say you
know this is for Congress to decide this
is for Congress do you really think that
your base is going to let you get away
with that for how long and I just would
love to see uh that if Biden were to
debate in a primary which probably won't
but he people have to debate in 2024.
this will be a great question for him to
have and he will say we will have a
commission to study yeah we know how
that goes Judge Jeanine Pirro
um Corey Bush she's loud she is I guess
influential in the squad how many is in
the squad four well they added a guy oh
okay does he get special privileges by
the way if you're the only male yeah he
gets to go in the ladies room
so will will this catch fire at all no
70 of Americans are against it that's
number one number two I just listened to
Corey Bush who by the way Corey Bush and
Rashida Talib apparently they voted
against a resolution to honor police
officers killed in the line of duty I
mean yeah they're Real Americans but
anyway
um she just said Corey Bush we need what
was a 91 trillion dollars uh so that we
can then send the money abroad wait a
minute I thought this was some repay you
for slavery now a Civil War people dying
that's not enough we need to get the
money to send it abroad for other people
no this is absurd what it's doing is
it's creating the anticipation just like
uh Newsome did he signed the task force
he signed it when I got back and then he
comes back and he actually said you know
this isn't really all about money but
what they're doing is they're creating
division a possibility of hope that it
might happen and then creating the
division of US versus them mentality we
are owed this and it's ridiculous Harold
Ford Jr so judge you we I think we all
know we have a history of redress uh in
our country
um and whether it's a government agency
doing something wrong to an American
citizen who then is entitled to money we
had it with the Japanese uh who were in
turn uh wrongly uh during World War II
so we we agreed even when we talked
about this with California I believe
Jess I want to put words in your mouth
but that there was a harm done done
through slavery now some of these
proposals and plans here and we
shouldn't allow the presenters of this
idea to distract us from the reality of
what happened and if indeed we should be
thinking about uh some form of redress
on the part of some people now I would
agree with Dana 14 trillion dollars is
or 90 well I heard her say 90 I think 97
trillion judge that's not going to 90
did you say 96 I think that's what I
think that's what the congresswoman said
she wants well that's I don't know the
bills but whatever the case we shouldn't
let that distract from what we're doing
and she these numbers I'm not I'm not
certain that that it there that the
numbers even arrived that with a
mathematical equation that that is
justifiable so I hope as the person that
sits in that chair Tom most of the time
Greg and I talked about education and
business investment and figuring out
ways to get guns out of certain
communities where people have more guns
and access to things that they really
need those are the things we should be
talking about and if this conversation
is a catalyst for something like that
there's an instigation for something
like that then we'll be positive but we
should be rest assured we're not going
to get to 14 trillion dollars for that
matter anywhere close to that but we
should also not deny that there's a
history of redress in our country and
compensating people for wrongdoing
towards them yeah including the Native
Americans I think yes we can go back a
lot right how far are we going to go
back that's the question no we got to go
forward now history history shows that
slavery was our original sin so okay
Harold Ford Jr hi winner Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now